welcome to this video playing remastered
tactic was from Hungary trying to
remember his name let let me check
Zoltan mid VG okay
so we have a queen pawn opening yeah
yeah I couldn't actually transpose to
the Sonya let me do something let's do
something funny it's a little bit risky
but I'm going to transpose to this myth
Mora oh it's not it's not obliging so we
get a series Sicilian hmm okay guess
what with d6 of b6 yes this kind of
lines mmm how does white play this
actually I have looked at this from them
from the black perspective some some
years ago hmm I really don't know how it
is played ship somewhere probably I
don't know just black play Bishop e6 Oh
Bishop e7 here it both makes some sense
of course okay probably just going to to
develop here I'd like to get rid of the
knight obviously hmm maybe you need to
control before at some point the night
before anything is not not happening
would like to get a knight - to e4 but
that's not not easy to accomplish okay
so I got him at the end he's taking
himself on d3 so that's that's good news
okay so taking this probably
should should get rid of this night yeah
I guess with the Queen Queen might serve
me well on the C file okay Luke c8 I
have Queen d3 weather with the temple
mm-hmm why do I put the bishop I can
also play Queens now right this is
probably okay
just get this get this piece developed
night night to the five-year okay okay I
have Bishop g5 coming
let's see Bishop g5 two to trade this
off yeah I guess so my bishop is really
a silly piece here on a form and if he
takes I might take with the night plane
94 okay I don't I don't expect him to
take but I have interesting I know it is
a bit hmm what can I not take on age six
is this this is so idiotic
I have rupee for g4 coming and I think
this is just working really don't I
don't get it I think I can really just
take whereas where's the defense I have
with with the back rank but still if I
take and play rookie form what what does
the defense will g-force I'm covering c1
check
and and and over or or not
look g4 and and over okay so here this
is not this is not flat-out winning hmm
really not if I give the check here
Wow is this not winning and this would
be very disappointing takes maybe I must
take take Knight takes Queen g6 notch hi
hi this is melon and I made it on c1 I
take here
well I'm stunned that there is this this
moves oh I didn't know didn't see that
at all time warning
okay I must I must I must play move I
only have one minute left but shake
right King f7 now this still seems to
still seems to hold Jack mackee an O
king f7 ahead and check this is chance
indeed winning for me but I only have 40
seconds number three pawns I should
really be enough I still have an attack
make sure I not get any back rank any
back rank things is happening and then
95 I can't give one check on you one
check
and probably something easier timewise
but three points yeah just that just
push the pawns now black resigns three I
was I was there I was too stunned by a
five I mean this is really not working
I'm pretty sure okay
another compass giving it as equal
interesting so let's let's check this
rook c8 is the only the only defense
I guess otherwise rookie for g4 is
really deadly on Knight g5 like takes
Queen takes King edge a droopy four so
if he does if he plays a stupid move
then then this is the the cleanest win
he must take check rookie four and then
you really get this so this is the only
move jack I capture and now if I really
overlooked that okay after after being
shocked for a while I actually took them
which I probably must do and he took
with the bishop and this losses this is
what I actually expected and then my
idea was to need to first give the check
check and then then probably retreat and
continue from here ninety five is a big
threat
what is the complicating here slight
edge to black this is the type of
evaluation that is always hard to
understand 98 mm 98 now cam it covers g5
so 95 is probably not not very
successful here you can take and play
something like
you know okay this is definitely not
enough computer gives Queen age seven
okay
Queen age seven is planning and i2g 5
because this happen is unprotected and
insured wants to run the age porn giving
you this as equal this is the line that
the compas suggesting with a repetition
sometimes this happens it's a weird form
of equilibrium mmm well very very hard
to to say and he went to Bishop f6 very
quickly and after that he's probably
toast
it took me ages to him to see that this
is of course not winning not queen g6
I'm just mating here next month
basically you know like this checkmate
I know slow in the morning yeah yeah I
can check and and win win the whole
bunch of pieces yes
family game nevertheless I hope you
enjoyed it thanks for watching